[Music]
well
we're trying to figure out how to break
down this episode which i've tentatively
called
state and power and i think we've
settled on something
it's going to be hegel versus posthagel
and really one of the things that i want
to bring up in the discussion is that
the most uh visceral reversion from
hegel is nazism
that's where adorno horkheimer the
frankfurt school and all the french guys
they all say
no you can't trust the state because of
nazism and they all try to find
hegelian roots in that kind of
spiritedness
hmm i don't know if anyone else is
thinking in that direction that's or
just fascism
i mean karl popper famously
located the root of all the 20th
century's problems in hegel right
and going back further than that plato
uh and i think most
serious commentators now think that this
kind of liberal
analytic distaste program seriously
overstated the case and missed a lot of
what was
unique in liberal and higgle's
philosophy but if you look on the
political right especially there's still
a lot of
popularity and traction in this
narrative particularly amongst like pop
intellectuals right and even even saying
that there's a bunch of leftist
interpretations of hegel like foremost
is zizek
but uh it's it's brought up often as
no there's spontaneity and hegel don't
worry about it
yeah it was even before the nazis though
i mean i don't see that but i'm
too lazy to read hegel again anyway i
did it once
i mean the frankfurt school really came
into its own in the inter-war
period so they're just thinking about
fascism in general
nazism hadn't quite emerged yet right
although would come in the 30s but yeah
they they'll take or dorno's thing is
he'll take anybody's philosophy and show
you how it'll lead to fascism
yeah all right so everybody got their
headphones in everybody got their mics
on
yeah it's recording now all right we
are ready to go hello everyone listeners
friends you are listening to the pill
pod today i thought we're not gonna go
pro or anti anything as a podcast
because we've done a lot of those and
there's more to come but today
we are just going to call ourselves the
podcast after hegel
so today we have a lot to get through or
maybe
not a lot to get through we're only
doing two words and we're going to deal
with two words for probably
six weeks or so and those two words are
state
and power today is going to be a
relatively open
discussion because i want to sort of
plan based on how this discussion goes
what we're going to be talking about in
the next few weeks
but when we're talking about state and
power it's really the transition from
hegel to everything after hegel in terms
of
uh political philosophy specifically
so as philosophically minded people who
have done comps exams
a few thoughts should immediately pop
into your head when you hear these terms
um state and power the first is hegel
who is the
foremost philosopher of the state he
thought that the state was the
manifestation of that con or the
resolution of the contradiction between
in uh universal in particular
um and he thought that the state was a
realization of freedom on earth not a
specific state but the abstract notion
of state we can get into that
um and then power is critiqued by
everyone that we usually talk about
on a critical theory podcast which is
marx nietzsche foucault
deliz frankfurt school etc
so of course this is a broad topic we're
just gonna see how it goes
um i have high hopes but we'll see we
might get
stuck in the weeds on something but with
us today
we have a full deck of cards
cards anyway
we got a politics guy victor how you
doing victor pretty good
pretty good semiotics guy who in this
case
doubles as an expert in the frankfurt
school
no no
not an expert in frankfurt school what
the [ __ ] hello man you're one of the
smartest people i
hear talk about it
um then then matt mcmanus who
who doesn't have a guy named but you
know everyone knows him
thanks man if you've been on the
internet lately yeah
and with us i like to pick fights with
us i know we're a bro
podcast and it's only gonna get more
bro-y today because we have girl bro
with us marion
[Laughter]
girl bro hello and miriam
has been brought on here for her
expertise in foucault
thank you like i spent a substantial
amount of time reading
about foucault like four years of math
i don't know yeah so in terms of the
text that you're dealing with or the uh
region of foucault that you're dealing
with because obviously he published a
lot what would you say is your
foremost area uh when reading fuco
um honestly i i prefer the biopolitic
stuff and that's what i
like that like interests me uh about
foot car
um uh i mean
if i have to say like i hate it the most
having to go through like
uh the the earlier texts right like
those are so heavy and i remember being
so lost
which one which was
that stuff yeah like yeah like
uh when he develops these whole
inceptions about the episteme
right and the whole whole history of
like well his conceptualization of like
ideas and yeah i think the system of
objects is beaudriard you're thinking of
the order of things yeah
oh excuse me sorry right [ __ ] plastic
pills
yeah with his bias
yeah no i read a book recently by roger
scrutin it was called fools frauds and
fire brands thinkers of the new left
and it's everything you would expect
from a roger scrutin book just
nasty nasty nasty but i was actually
surprised because
when it came to the section on foucault
he did actually claim that he was a good
writer and i think you always have to
qualify that by saying
he became a good writer you know after
he gained a little bit of confidence and
he realized that he didn't have to write
like a post structuralist anymore
you get into like discipline and punish
in the history of sexuality
there's a really vivid and kind of
interesting
uh aesthetic value to his work right
especially like those chapters about
torture and sex and
all that kind of stuff well i remember a
quotation by
foucault i have not checked up on it i
don't know if he actually said it
but he said something like oh don't
worry about the first 10 pages of
anything you write you can fill it with
any [ __ ] and the more [ __ ]
the better because that makes you sound
more interesting
yeah there you go it sounds like it
sounds like early football to me
so anyway we have a full cast of
characters here
uh and we are going to deal with again
two words state and power so i thought
because i probably know less than
anybody in the room on either of those
things but i do know
hegel's version of state when when
you're historicizing hegel and i
remember
listener not knowing a [ __ ] thing
about hegel and everybody talks about
hagel blah blah blah endlessly until
they're blue in the face
then doing comps i finally got a little
glimpse of it
and really the thing that you have to
understand is
necessity and freedom as a contradiction
that is resolved so necessity comes from
nature that's what you have to do that
means you don't have free will
free will means you can act uh
independently of nature you have your
own
agency this is what you do when you're
being rational
you escape from nature in a sense and
this is one of the contradictions that's
resolved in hegel and for him
this occurs in the state so before
you have i guess in in in hegel's
context it's an early modern
context and he's looking at france from
germany which is a
fractured smattering of of duchies and
so on
and he says in the state the nation
state as we would understand it
you have finally uh your human freedom
enmeshed with your political freedom so
it's kind of the highest state of human
development because you're not just uh
an animal but you have political free
will
and then the political free will is
guaranteed by this abstraction or the
universal
which is the state that's all the
introduction to hegel i'm gonna give
right
we could go on and on and that's
probably crudely oversimplified
but uh then we move over to the 20th
century
and everybody thinks hegel is [ __ ]
balls
everybody that i read these days you
know foucault
left i don't even know how to pronounce
that francophone
but uh deliz everybody is just taking a
giant dump on hegel
all day long except for jack except for
the one exception uh lacan as well i
guess he wouldn't he didn't count but
uh in terms of political philosophy
everyone thinks hegel is the worst they
think he's totalizing
they think he allows for no spontaneity
no creativity
right um and then so what we're trying
to deal with
is how to deal with the state not
necessarily hegel but the state that
we're living under
um which doesn't appear to be all that
good
for critical theorists i would like to
make uh
note a little irony from richard byner's
recent book die interest minds which is
that
a lot of these french philosophers did
like abandon hegel and hegelianism but
the philosopher
the german philosopher that they turned
to was nietzsche who
if anything held far more reactionary
views than hegel ever did right
hegel at the end of his career was kind
of a
conservative-ish liberal you know uh
whereas nietzsche was very happy to say
things like
burn them all and let god decide the
rest except god doesn't exist
so they're just going to suffer power
yeah did you say that
we also have to we also just before we
get to you we have to recognize
the other trajectory that goes from
germany to france which is marx
marx influenced obviously the frankfurt
school and all the neo-marxist altuzera
rancier
etc so we're dealing with these dual
trajectories everybody is dumping on
hegel but they aren't
totally they're kind of incorporating
hegelian concepts
and it may seem more um
antimonious than it actually is they're
they're
they're reaction reacting to create
something new so with that
i'm gonna there has to be a hegelian
recolonization reconciliation with hegel
right so with that i am going to kick it
to the floor
we have an uh a contradiction
to resolve if you will state and power
and i'm gonna throw it to the floor well
may i i just would like to uh
so two things quickly just i missed
something that matt said earlier i was
wondering
were you you were was that the book the
ronald [ __ ] book the uh
is it rich ronald i feel bad ronald
sorry yeah he's at u of t so
you probably i took his class yeah i
took his classes that he was based on
that book oh
well i'll send him uh my accommodations
because i really like it we could
actually probably interview him one time
on this podcast if we wanted to
oh that'd be awesome but anyway sorry
metacasting now
that would be just as an aside but i did
want to come back to something that uh
pills was saying like um
so that definition of the state you know
it's funny i think when i was doing the
the political theory core course i feel
like the week on hegel was like the week
when or the two weeks on hegel was the
week when i was busy we were reading the
philosophy of right and i felt like i
didn't really pay that much attention
during
those two weeks but it's interesting
like the way the abstract way that you
described it and
that did ring a bell for me and like i
don't know just thinking back to like
the history of political philosophy
before that like i wonder
how different do you think that
definition of the state is to like what
for example hobbes
was talking about because in some ways
like isn't hobbs justifying like
the state power if you if you think of
leviathan estate
as needing to protect human beings from
necessity of nature right like
the whole point is you need a state to
protect um
uh people citizens from dying a horrible
death as a result of i guess you could
call it necessity right
because for him nature is this uh war of
all against all right so i don't know if
you had any thoughts about that or how
you think that's different than
like what hegel was talking about there
or i don't know do you want me to
respond to that
maybe i don't know okay so the
distinction there's two distinctions
i only mentioned one but the first is
freedom and necessity
which is nature versus like free will
but the second
is abstract versus or abstract versus
concrete right so uh
hob's estate is very abstract in in the
sense that it never
existed and still hasn't existed right
right
it's a it's a model but within the
leviathan state
you don't actually have freedom
to be self-conscious you're only your
freedom is to
follow the law that has been placed over
you in that context
right right so hegel state is more like
you have the
free will to be an absolutely free
political subject
and self-reflective um and it's not
about following
the rules in that case you can think
freely because you have all of history
behind you
and you can reflect on history as being
the thing that brought
your consciousness into being and your
allows your freedom to
express itself good good that's a good
distinction to make yeah
i i would say also that i think that
you're onto something and i think hey
goal
like every figure that he deals with
doesn't just dismiss hobbs right and i
think there is something to this idea
that
the body politic by establishing the
sovereign commits a free act
and establishes the violation and
achieves a certain level of freedom
through the law right
what i think hegel tries to add to
hobbes um
primarily if you're a critic of kant is
taking these very aristotelian themes of
recognition the desire for sociality
uh the desire for meaningful symbols uh
that people share collectively and he
incorporates that all into the tapestry
by saying well
in order to make your freedom
substantive and to last it's not enough
just to be allowed to do whatever you
want
even as a country you also need to
achieve recognition from the other
and you do that by establishing these
kinds of institutions
uh for instance the monarchy right right
uh where he says you know
sovereign isn't necessarily going to be
like the sovereign leviathan
what it's going to be is a singular
manifestation of the unity
as a kind of symbol right and it might
not necessarily even have any
significant power allocated in the
monarch
but nonetheless there's a tremendous
amount of affective significance
um and a very important function that it
serves uh to have a monarch in place
right
no that makes sense when hegel talks
about the state it seems like an
enlightened
despotism i mean yeah this is this is
with hindsight
of course so um and
i'm just going to say this is a caveat
because born is going to come here and
probably wreck our [ __ ] on hegel
all of my interpretation of hegel comes
from french people who hate him
and then and then my comp exams where i
actually had to read him so
i might be biased in the wrong way
towards him and i'm gonna
just straight on admit that but that's
yeah that's my reading is that
freedom and necessity the contradiction
is resolved and
abstraction and concrete the
contradiction is resolved
so the state is like the full
manifestation of reason in history right
well i think that's a good i mean i
think that's
that's a good reading of what hegel like
wanted his account to be and i guess
maybe what matt was bringing up well is
like
or implying at least is you know like
like to what extent is it really
manifesting this freedom in
a substantive way and to what extent is
it just like maybe an enlightened
despotism where
like the freedom is i don't know like
maybe it's like because i think that's a
lot of the critique from the left of
hegel right is that it's
it's not really uh it's not really
freedom in a meaningful sense it's kind
of this abstract
conceptions why don't why don't we just
start off from coming down from the
clouds because i don't
think that anyone is going to find this
particularly interesting but yeah
how do we how do we negotiate let's just
say
uh you know capitalist democracy
neoliberal democracy how does that
reason with the state and then how do we
critique that
even leaving hagel behind i actually i
have something to say on this because
actually this is the main point i wanted
to make in relation to it
but basically i think it's important to
look at the hegelian account of the
state
now more than ever before because if you
look at like the
ascendancy of right-wing populism around
the globe are you look at the way that
people have tried to manage the kovac
crisis the institutions that they're
turning to
are the state and the sense of
collective identity
and shared values and shared care that
it's meant to manifest
right and a lot of the people who are
attracted to populist rhetoric say
precisely that
we don't want global institutions
they're affiliated with global capital
which is disinterested
which doesn't appreciate our freedom and
its particularity
and so we want a resuscitation of the
nation state as the primary locus
uh political legitimacy and attention
that's a great point
uh and i know a lot of us don't like
that and i don't either because you know
i hate
right-wing populism in a lot of ways uh
but i do think it's worth
questioning why this is appealing now
because that would be a rejection
of the hegelian development towards like
perfect particularity in a universal
state
right let's see you caught me at
unawares with all this hegel talk
all right so let's just why don't we
just like
put haggle on the shelf then because
this is kind of an alienating discussion
for anybody
well i think i could maybe pick up on
something
like that that i think that matt was
talking about like the the
the appeal of like the way in which
capitalism seems to be taking power away
from the state and i thought maybe we
should actually make
because i think you you defined what the
state was for hegel but
uh pills but like you know how would we
like what
what's the difference between power and
and the state like maybe we should just
talk about broadly like those two
since those are the two words maybe we
should just talk about power broadly now
and then like think about how those two
things link
i was i was thinking about it and the
way
i mean what first pops into my head when
i hear the state is the early modern
state first of all the development of
the early modern state
yeah so what by the time we get past the
whole divine right of kings things
we get into hobbs and lock and that
they're so radical because they're
articulating like a secular state
and it's the social contract right so
the idea that we give up
our own personal power so that it can be
exercised on our behalf by a higher
authority
right which then keeps society in order
and staves off the state of nature
so power is almost legitimated
by the social contract and it's wielded
by the state itself right right the
state the state is
is wielding the sword and power is the
sword itself
kind of thing if you need a metaphor for
it
out of curiosity maybe marion can answer
this question but
it's something that always perplexed me
can anyone give like a working
definition of what power is
like because again i sometimes think
kanye west probably has a better
consumption of it than like
social scientists we like to invoke it
it's like powers here
power is there if says power is
everywhere but
i remember even vocalians if you ask
them like well what does we call mean by
power they're just like well it's
ubiquitous all right what can you say
about it i'll be on that so does anybody
know how to define well i think oh yeah
go ahead sorry mariano
we have the foucault experts exactly
exactly
no no i was just going to say that there
are many definitions of power
i used to teach like political science
and
there is really a huge right array of
definitions so i think that
one that's usually a common place is uh
the ability the capacity a
whatever actor right might be an
institution an individual uh
to just exercise like i'd be able to
change
someone like someone else's behavior
right and i
and i think that like understands power
that way although he
differentiates three different types of
power in um
exercise in society do you want to name
them
yeah yeah like what you have like the
what he calls a legal one that
comes from the state right all of what
you were saying hey right like
uh like the authority that comes from
the state through the law
and also of course through for example
uh
other institutions associated state and
then there is
uh of course what made his name what
made him very famous which was
disciplinary power right or like all the
disciplinary institutions right
that govern um our bodies right
and that like basically yeah like
covering our bodies i'll just like
keep it perfectly there and then there's
his latest account of power which is
biopower
and it's more about governing uh
populations and just going back to what
appeals
say before or ask before like i think
um at some point
like 20th century political theorist or
philosophers
kind of uh not only because of what
happened of course
in terms of historical events right the
two wars etc
like nazis and fascism there was in some
sort of recognition that
associating power with state power was
just a very limited account
of what power is right there are other
sources of power that are as important
and that are
as uh relevant maybe to
shape right uh the individual and
society and i think that's why
someone like who call became so famous
for right and other
uh thinkers not only for right yeah
varian would you associate that
that like i guess shouldn't say quoi
part of power
with ideology is that a fair connection
to make
oh yeah definitely like uh um like but
when you say associate like
you mean establish like more specific i
i just think ideology is a way of
exercising power right like just that
means
like yeah like they're also again
like that's a problem in the social
sciences right in the humanities you
have like many competing definitions
contested definitions
for things but i think one of the
definitions of ideology
and why ideology sometimes is perceived
right this kind of
public enemy is because it has stated to
power right like and
specifically sometimes to the power
exercise from the state right yeah do
you think uh disciplinary power
is like ideology i guess if i'm thinking
about like the more although in
definition of ideology which i think
like
jack picks up on a lot um is that
because i guess when i think about the
disciplinary power that foucault
are like it's almost like the everyday
level that sort of monitors people's
like the way people respond to norms in
their society and the way they
the sort of affective feeling they get
to like not fitting into norms i don't
know if you agree with that
let me let me just jump in here yeah
because we just mentioned a whole bunch
of terms
and i'm not gonna expect that everybody
knows what these terms mean yeah
first is legal power this is the law's
power
to punish you uh right so that's very
direct
like you know if you break the law
usually more to
compel you with the threat of punishment
not necessarily
you know you know in your own mind if
you break the law
a cop is going to arrest you basically
then you have disciplinary power and
disciplinary power is not the threat of
being arrested but it's
uh enclosure right so
schools
okay okay okay i'm just trying to get
three easy definitions out of the way so
we can keep talking about it right
so one savoir pufar law power
second one school power and then
three is biopower i don't think we need
to go into that yet but you
you internalize each of these states of
power into your own mind that restrict
that forces you to restrict your own
activity
i think is a fair way to say it because
that's kind of what miriam said
in terms of you can compel someone else
to do what you want
and ideology is a version of this
disciplinary power that
makes people not act out because they
are afraid
in their own mind of being punished in
advance of ever doing anything wrong
right sure i mean i heard this anecdote
about a person in saskatchewan who was a
very prototypical canadian
where it was like 12 o'clock at night
they went to a stoplight
it was a red and it was midnight and
there was no one probably for 100
kilometers
and this guy stayed and waited the light
out
rather than go through it because that
was the kind of
more that he had internalized and i was
like in some ways this guy is like the
ideal fuconian subject
right yeah see i guess
i guess what power really is is it it's
deeply
it's deeply entangled with just our
theory of causalities
basically how things get done how things
happen
i mean there's the scientific definition
of power obviously but we
in the humanities and the social
sciences tend to look at it
as a more dispersed impersonal kind of
phenomenon not like not just my power to
lift things and
and do physical activities but also to
compel people
or to have foreknowledge about an event
right like one could say that
at the beginning of this covid crisis
when stocks were sold
before everybody knew that was an
exercise of power
right it's power isn't just power power
also
works a lot like class right you can't
just freeze it and look at it it always
has to be manifested
embodied in some act right so it's a
widely dispersed phenomenon that has
many different sources
and it's associated with the theory of
causality in
either culturally or politically or
legally speaking yeah
go ahead no what i
want to ask is like is that always true
because it seems to me that in some
cases
versus the internalization of legal
mores power operates most effectively
when
it is displayed through an act uh but
there's no
overt reference to the source of power
itself
right um you know they have the old
anecdote about you know
how it is that if you see the king and
his authority and operation
that probably means the state is falling
apart uh and
sovereign power is at its most effective
when there's really no need to display
it because everyone knows it's operating
it's oddly present and so on and so
forth
so like what kind of performances or
gestures need to be done
to demonstrate the continued operation
of power
without making it so visible that people
can call it into question
this is what i was going to ask miriam
because i think these examples are going
to be
really helpful to people that are
listening to this so
i always can speak in abstract terms but
i always have like a very concrete form
in my head so when you're thinking of
foucault
what is the most concrete example that
you
have uh stick it in your brain marian
the
famous chapter at the end of this like
uh surveyor
pune right when he speaks about the
panopticon and he says this is how
society and the norm precisely works
right like
and this relates to what victor was
saying and what matt was saying right
like the fact that
uh we internalize all these norms in
society right
and even though we we act as if someone
wasn't forcing them even though there's
no one there enforcing them or even if
we
don't know there's someone they're
enforcing them this is
and one of the reasons i like for god
the most is because he says
this power becomes part of our
subjectivity
right it's basically becomes who we are
yeah i mean my favorite quote by him was
always the soul
is the prison of the body right i
thought that was really
pretty i think i'm going to intervene
i'm sorry i'm going to intervene on
behalf of our viewers because we had
a word drop that people are not going to
know what it means
probably unless you've read fuco but the
panopticon oh yeah
is a circular prison where there's a
tower at the center
and there's a guard in the tower or not
in the tower you don't know
but if you're a prisoner in one of the
cells you have to act as if
there's a guard in the tower whether or
not they're watching you
you can't see inside so the direct
correlation to our
society would be um surveillance cameras
or security cameras
you don't know if anyone's watching on
the other side of that at any point
but they could be so that like miriam
just said you act
as if they are there whether or not
there's anybody there so that becomes a
part of your own behavior
whether or not there's actually power
there you don't know but the power
itself is that relationship
which is exactly i think fits with the
example that matt was giving of like
that person at the red light right i
guess you could argue that
he doesn't know if there's a red light
camera right could up could be a red
light camera but you act as if there's
someone watching or that there's a red
light camera or whatever
i think the story is better if there is
no red light camera and he's just
sitting there by himself anyway well
there usually isn't
yeah yeah i also just think it's such a
canadian story right like there's this
guy and he's like well that's the law
though and you know i'm not going to go
through this red light even if there's
not another person for 150 kilometers
well they probably can't afford red
light cameras in
saskatchewan selling canola all day
i don't know how much money canola makes
these days but
so i wanted to pick up on something
before that marion was talking about the
way like it's sort of a constitutive of
subjectivity
power and i think often like the the
term power especially in leftist
discourse is uh
kind of like uh talked about in a mostly
negative light
i would say but i think especially in
the fukudian definition if i remember
correctly when i was reading discipline
and punish like
there's really a strong sense in which
power is is productive right it's not
just something that that
just that like stops people from acting
but in some ways it creates the
conditions
for people to be like it creates
subjectivity it like
it constitutes a lot of relations that
maybe wouldn't be possible without it so
like i think the fukodian definition
kind of broadens what it means because
it's like
you know in some ways you like be i
don't know like i felt like some of the
implications of
of the account and discipline and
punishes you know to some extent
subjectivity itself may not even
be possible without power can you
furnish us with an example
of its productivity well like the fact
that um
our personalities like so language our
personalities
like that our cultures or like our norms
anything that anything that like gives
us a sense
that in a social situation this is
appropriate and this isn't
is a result of power but that's also
kind of what makes us human beings
is like to have some sort of sense of
what's appropriate and what's not
appropriate
in a given situation without that right
like um
i mean in some ways i i actually i think
i've only read like a little bit of
madness in civilization so maybe this
isn't actually an example from that
but like it could be like is it people
who
suffer from mental illness right maybe
they or like some
some types of mental illness people some
of these people haven't instilled like
any norms in them
in themselves at all so they're kind of
like outcasts because they don't fit
into
like uh any they don't they they almost
can't have an intersubjective
relationship with
uh with with people in a society so so
in a sense i think it like it creates
the conditions for
like a shared world you could argue
power
one one thing i'm gonna say before
anyone else says anything
we're getting very abstract and every
time i'm going to press you for examples
unless you bring it up on your own so
make sure to do it i was going to give
two examples uh
first one was precisely
making reference to what you said before
like uh democratic liberal capital
new liberal societies whatever you want
to characterize them right
think about the uh
like all the devices we are using to be
to make this podcast possible
right like they are the product not only
of course of technological innovation
but a lot of complex uh arrangements of
the political economy of states that
make this invention possible right that
allows us to communicate
and that would be like i think in focus
uh
since this uh kind of non-repressive
productive right like um
outcomes if you want to look at that way
of power and the second example it was
gonna be
was like our survival as the population
of a state
right when when you mentioned biopower
right like before
by basically focal refers to biopower as
this interest
the state takes on keeping us alive
right and today i may be like that me as
victor was saying this can be associated
to a lot of negative
like things like this state denying you
your right to abortion
or not having access to healthcare right
but if you think in another light
like the state also took an interest on
having us
living maybe out of selfish reasons
because they want us product right
right for their own developmental state
but even under those selfish reasons
right
eventually the state created the
conditions
for populations to thrive um
you could talk about health care as an
example of bio power
because you get free health care of
course but they're also tracking
every movement you do in there so is it
good or is it bad there's not an answer
to that
it's obviously better to have free
health care than to not but it's an
example of biopower
sorry matt continue no no i i just
was making exactly the same point which
is that if you look at what's going on
right now with the kova crisis
a lot of people are calling for the
state to intervene in a biological
manner
precisely because they think it's the
only institution or set of institutions
however we want to characterize it
that's actually able to maintain the
health of the body politic through sound
policy and so on and so forth right
and there's a strong democratic mandate
for this and a lot of countries across
the globe so
biopower even doesn't have to be
intrinsically negative right maybe it
can have a useful and even
democratically legitimated function but
generally
when we talk about power we're thinking
about
the centralized authority and the
exercise of power
from above like from the state level
down to the people right like my
impression of
of bio politics and bio power that
foucault talks about is it it's what
characterizes the modern state
so you move from sovereign power which
literally just means the power to kill
so it's like don't [ __ ] with me or i'll
kill you otherwise go do what you want
pay your landlord
to you get to the modern state which
says
like i'm going to collect demographic
information
and now i'm going to understand what
general age my population is
what their health is what their gender
is what their
what their whatever what their jobs are
that's more like character
it characterizes the modern state in a
fundamental way it's not just like
something that we talk about later on
nowadays from now that we're all like
leftists and woke and [ __ ] i mean
apparently the french state even
collected data on how often the citizens
were having sex
just because they thought like well this
is an important bit of health
information to know since
if people are having sex two or three
times a week that'll lead to a healthier
more psychologically stable population
so if it's lower than that we're going
to have to enact policies to encourage
it
it's either foucault or delus quoting
foucault
i can't remember which because i've been
absorbing both
this week but they said napoleon
single-handedly
dragged an entire nation from sovereign
power
into this managerial disciplinary power
by collecting census since his data is
the perfect example
of biopower i had a quick question for
everyone because i've been absorbing
this kind of literature
partly in preparation for this but also
just partly because it interests me
uh it's kind of 1990s work by wendy
brown and judith butler
particularly their books uh states of
injury and the psychic life of power
and i think you could also date this
argument to actually the frankfurt
school as well people like eric from
uh where they said essentially you know
these french philosophers in particular
always see
power as something that people try to
resist or they submit to
because they can't resist it but it's
almost always uniformly viewed
as a negative thing from a psychological
standpoint uh and what brown and judith
butler following
you know people like eric from said is
actually a lot of people can really
crave a degree of submission to power
and they go back to our talk last week
one of the things that they pointed out
was that
a lot of identity politics movements now
that frame their identity around being a
victim
in some sense crave a powerful authority
figure
to juxtapose themselves against and that
becomes foundational for their sense of
self right
unless i have this figure this
antagonist
who's a power that's impacting my
identity i wouldn't know who i was
so i must always make reference to who i
am uh in terms of my victimization right
really controversial thesis uh really
racy kind of stuff but i was wondering
what we thought about that particularly
given all this hoopla about
cancel culture victim culture pc and all
that stuff
well i i find it to be an interesting
thesis and i feel like to some extent
zhiz has said similar things right about
like um
sort of the way like a people like uh
whatever politically correct discourse
or people who do a lot of uh
on the politically correct left sort of
their identity is sustained by
being in opposition to this thing that
is trying to
uh oppress them and i think to some
extent like the
i think like right-wingers who are like
kind of obsessed and fixated on sjw's
these days
to some extent i feel like their
identity is also now being sustained by
the fantasy of the neo-marxists trying
to destroy uh freedom or something like
that uh
there's something uh there's something
to sustaining
or something productive of the fantasy
of a stable identity
that comes from being in opposition to
something i think
that is like you don't have to go to
right wingers for that that's
everywhere no that's no that's me oh
yeah well of course
that is plastic pills as an individual
i'm only going to get
my i'm only going to uh develop
my individual identity as resistance to
university as a resistance to state as
resistance to
yeah the order yeah well
i i just always thought this was really
interesting to kind of go off what
marion was saying right because
you know she's uh judy butler and when
he brown draw a lot of foucault right
and they say
he's absolutely right that power is
omnipresent and that
uh you know it creates certain kinds of
subjectivities and so on
uh but judith butler's point and the
psychic life of powers but we should
never underestimate how
people might actually crave this kind of
subordination
even if on the surface they want
resisted
right because if they don't have this
kind of sense of subordination
to push against what are they going to
do
with their lives right they might just
sit there and say well now it's all my
responsibility what i do
i alone am responsible for my actions
which means i alone i'm also responsible
for all my own failings
right which is not a position many of us
want to take
oh yeah marian does foucault ever
develop that thesis that people actually
want
to be you know controlled by space and
so on
i think i think he was hitting some like
kind of
note there when he said we're gonna
erase power right i don't know if he
kind of declared it like i say kind of
psychological need or some sort i just
think
he understood it was a fact right
or that's how i understand it and he
understood like
there is no social relation or no social
reality without power right that's why
this is why first kind of these
revolutionary aspirations
fail right because you get like this
some of them operate
under the assumption that they will
conquer power and then kind of eliminate
it right like in this kind of
um the power of the state for example
going back to canada
mark's line right that's it that's it
i like it so he would have vouched for
that you think if he hadn't
died or did he vote for that i don't
know oh no
no no i don't think so i don't think
fuco was invested at
all in in revolutionary ideas okay at
all
no it's just it's like fitting people
into boxes
i watched a documentary where he said
the happiest day
in his life was apparently dropping acid
going out into the desert with a couple
of buddies of his
and watching the sun set and this is the
same time we were
super involved in like the bdsm movement
in san francisco
trying all kinds of weird [ __ ] out um
and then they wrote
the history of sexuality right so i
don't know so
that's the answer we all need to do acid
and get into bdsm yeah or just
and that let's just get a little kinky
with it you know like
it's a little masochistic it's it's like
the reason why
why did why did kant make the
categorical imperative
so strict that nobody could follow it
because he liked getting punished he
wanted somebody to whip him
he wanted he wanted a dom daddy you know
he wanted somebody to bring the hammer
of justice down on his ass
if only had a daddy we wouldn't have
had to read the critique of uh no
practical reason he would have gone back
to his second critique and been like nah
do what you want man
it's all good but no he didn't have it
20 this is like our sort of i was
thinking about this before but it's it's
i'm thinking about it more now like
i remember when i was reading discipline
and punished i remember being kind of
frustrated by the light like the way he
wrote things to make
everything seem kind of nefarious like i
remember he was like he's like
you know the regularization and the
systematization of
everything and it's like and i remember
in my mind thinking like okay like
yeah like building codes like good we
should have building codes like things
need to be regulated things need to be
otherwise they're not gonna work and
you know even in bdsm circles right
which are like there's like
you know there's like rules right
there's like a bunch of like you know
don't do this
and whatever like it's extremely
strictured it's like it's extremely
strict
we have here's our safe words here's the
thing you can do it
but like but that's kind of the pleasure
in it right is like you can be
domed without the
while within the categories of that rule
base
yeah this sounds like a gj is this his
point or am i making that up
i don't know it definitely sounds like
it definitely sounds like something he
would say
we're talking about bdsm right while you
are while you are
smacking him in the face then
now i was making the zizek point because
he compares it to the
because it to courtly love right the
reason that the knight like
debases himself in front of the ladies
is because he wants
he's sort of uh he's role-playing like
the servant when
really he's the white male knight so
what the [ __ ] he doing kneeling to
anybody but
that's the that's the cultural code
right that's how power exerts
itself is through those internalized
mores
but i i was i had an idea i throw out
there i just want to say this
is going to sound really bad but i
thought you said courtney love for a
second eric and i'm like
really he wrote about like was like a
nirvana fan yeah i'm going there
i didn't know that no i i think power
like in the humanities i i kind of
resisted ever writing about power
because power just seemed to me like
today what vitalism was to the 19th
century
it's so ubiquitous it's so everywhere
and it's so
nowhere but it explains everything but
at the same time it explains
nothing it's just like vitalism is just
the living force that animates
all life power is the living force that
animates all
social life great we've outlined that
and and it's completely [ __ ] useless
so why don't we can you
although can you elaborate can you draw
attention to some
uh disciplines or projects that you
would say
require this element of power just to be
like there ubiquitously require this
element of power well no like because
power is the explanation for everything
in
certain circles of course yeah so give
me a circle give me an example
so i was dipping a little bit into bruno
latour and
if you don't if you know him great if
you don't know him he's
he he looks at the social and thinks
that it's the same way that i was just
saying it's this sort of
this hypothetical existing force that
somehow mysteriously acts
on us but it can't be found anywhere and
so when you talk about
social theory for example like why
i don't know why boys are boys and girls
or girls because so
society tells you you have to be one or
the other and then we don't
we're satisfied with that explanation we
don't ask then well why does it have to
be one or the other
we just cut it off right there and it
becomes this just mysterio that's what
i'm saying it becomes this mysterious
force there's no examples of it
because it's everywhere and nowhere
anything you can point to
my house is a result of power no no no i
mean
examples of oh yeah well then latour
latour thinks that way
because i have easy examples of people
who think that way
if you spend any amount of time on on
the internet then it's like
capital did this and capital did that
and capitals making these decisions
which is exactly this kind of ubiquitous
force
that has no particular yeah i mean it is
a bit like geister spirit too like
there's nothing you
you can't do anything but further unfold
geist or further
manifest power and it just becomes this
it's so
universal that it explains this is the
very first chapter of uh
hegel's logic is when you have something
that's everything it's also nothing at
the same time because it's pure
it has no properties whatsoever so uh
yeah
when people talk about power or capital
or patriarchy or all of these
words that just are meant to be er
explanations they have no
specific properties which is exactly
waifu ko wrote every book the way that
he did and it's like let's sit in a bed
in a psychiatric hospital what happens
when you're in that bed people come and
give you medicine when you stand up they
ask you why you're standing up and this
is the way that power is internalized
by specific actions not by miasma power
doesn't come into your head it's put
into your head
by the actions of these authorities and
uniformed authorities specifically
around you
and this is what my theory of cause and
effect comes into play again about it
because
the in the latin terms right the
explanandum the thing we're dumb about
the thing we want to know
becomes the exponents it becomes a thing
by which we explain
everything and in this grand reversal
power
and society and geist and vitalism they
become
the things that we want to explain they
transform into the things that just
explain everything and then in doing so
they explain nothing because they're
just
that's metaphysical it's useless well
i do want to say i do think there is
something difficult
claimed that power pervades all human
relations right i mean
i think he makes the case pretty clearly
that even in seemingly neutral
disciplines
uh like medical inquiry right you can
see the influence of power
when it comes to things like hiring or
which scientific paradigm is
respected at any given time and so on
and so forth right
what i think the problem is eric's not
criticizing foucault he's criticizing
people who read foucault and go oh power
now we have an explanation for
everything
oh yeah you know i'm getting to them
because i don't like them either uh
because
one of the best readers of uco that i've
encountered recently
marion recommended him actually was
thomas lenke who wrote a very good book
uh on poco's governmentality and he said
the problem with developing such a total
critique
is that eventually you feel
there's not only no reason to try to
resist power anymore
but you don't even have any conceptual
resources with which to resist it right
because
any evaluative judgment you make is just
going to
establish a new form of hegemonic
ideology or hegemonic discourse
it's going to be just as bad as the one
before so why bother trying to resist
anything
and i think this is the problem with
trying to say power is everywhere
yes it may be everywhere but that
doesn't mean we can't make evaluative
judgments
using other methodological and
philosophical approaches
to try to decide what exercise of power
might be better than another right
like some of the examples we're bringing
out right like i don't think that
there's anything wrong
with an exercise of power to establish
sound building codes
or an exercise of power on behalf of
democracy to
try to establish universal health or to
make bdsm
all right
but i mean this is the problem that you
get with like uh these kind of
totalizing explanations that
are meant to just explain something but
then ultimately end up just encompassing
your entire worldview right
you lose the capacity to actually
evaluate from a normative or aesthetic
or whatever standpoint
which exercise is a power might actually
be helpful or useful
uh and which ones are probably worth
rejecting yeah it becomes like a fifth
element like an ether or a quintessence
it just stands in for what we can't
explain
but i mean yeah you're right about all
that the the and the approach to it is
to whenever you're
making a study of something like you're
doing organizational studies or gender
anything you have to carefully
circumscribe the context that you're
looking at
or else or if you've had no boundaries
then power again just becomes this sort
of all-encompassing
explanation of things yeah marianne when
you were doing your
uh your your thesis work did you
focus on a specific element of foucault
in application
uh what interest me was um
analyzing biopower in your liberal um
societies right like because to me back
then it seemed like
uh like neoliberalism entails a lot of
like unseen uses of this biopower that
were
that were deemed as acceptable uh
without being like criticized like
let's say traffic cameras right when you
now get like a camera
and it like basically uh snaps your
picture when you
commit like a traffic violation right
like we think that that's
kind of okay right because it prevents
like accidents or whatever but it's kind
of a way of like
surveillance right because it's used to
gather data about the population for
example right and
and also um it interests me
as a feminist in the way the state
approach uh
women's bodies for example right it's
their right
uh to control our bodies i think that's
another way like another
form of biopower and just going back to
this like yeah these concepts that are
all encompassing and then they end up
not encompassing anything
this idea of patrick your patriarchy
sorry i think and in some context
patriarchy can rather be for example
understood as biopower that's reactor
throwers like
women's bodies and that kind of stuff
i've driven in western mexico and there
wasn't a [ __ ] single
traffic camera that i ever saw in my
life
yes i agree like as as a mexican it's
very interesting because in
in western developed countries all the
academics are like oh this is something
that we have to oppose this is wrong and
as a mexican he's like no maybe
discipline is something
we need i think that yeah i think that
at least in
some parts of mexico they do need to see
oh they could use some
they could use some [ __ ] cameras
because it's just the intersection and
everyone's honking
like driving through each other's cars
being like
and i'm sitting there like no i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna go i'm gonna drive
into someone's car so that i'm sitting
in the middle of an intersection for
like
30 minutes anyway so i think we can
agree that that
power is never uh neutral but it
it's not always something negative
exactly
something to be decried it's not neutral
though
and even if we think it's sort of
beneficial it can turn
ugly in a in an instant like uh facial
recognition
technology or something like that well
which that's which is why i think
that's uh matt's like sort of um account
of
sort of the maybe the bet the better
question from a perspective of
political theory or like normative
political theory would be you know
what's
it's not so much like power escaping
power but more so like what
what are like better states of affairs
what are what's better uses of power and
what are the reasons
yeah or subverting power decentralizing
power
like avoiding these concentrations of
power that just seemed to be like
endemic to the neoliberal setup of
things right
like those those are ways like you're
not combating power
though you're exercising power just in a
sort of new way
exactly make it more egalitarian
democratic sort of exercise of power
instead of that sort of classic because
if if you're like a frenchman writing in
around the 60s you're probably very
concerned with authority and
centralization and fascism
and those sorts of things yeah i just
want to interject and say also i don't
think these are new
questions in some way like one of the
things that i always i think about one
uh this cursed me is like this is his
book the peloponnesian war
uh which has a lot of interesting
ruminations on when is power legitimate
when it's not
uh my favorite quote from that book is
when the democratic athenians land
on the island of the millions who are
reportedly an ally of them
and they're basically going to subjugate
this people and the millions are like
well how can you do that you know you
have this democracy and you believe in
individual freedom and civil rights and
so on
and the athenian delegation basically
says we're not going to [ __ ] you
we're better than that
uh we're not going to say that there's
some noble reason for this uh the reason
we're doing this is because the strong
do what they will
and the weak suffer what they must and
you're the weak and where they're strong
so get used to it right but kind of in
the millennium objection
is this notion that well if you were
exercising this power
for a democratic reason then maybe it'd
be legitimate maybe we'd even buy into
it right
but because you're just exercising it
for your pure self-interest
now it's illegitimate and we're going to
resist it right so
vicinity seemed to me to be pretty aware
that this was a problem right
uh and i imagine you could look at other
greek authors and chinese authors and
there'd be
parallel discussions at that point and i
think the fun thing about talking about
power too is
is it's very like the way we see power
most is in mundane things
and in everyday things right like like
an example i was just reading about
is like of course like to drink thirst
is a biological need but then everything
from there on is power what you drink
how you drink
when you drink it whether you drink
green tea or coke
like those are all power structures that
are negotiated
in everyday cultural discourses
depending on where you're from
and what time period you're from and all
that sort of thing like power
is very mundane like that's we talk
about power like these grand
applications the peloponnesian war and
spartans but really like power is
something like like even when you're
talking about women's bodies right like
fashion is one of the most fascistic
applications of power to women's bodies
you can imagine and it's so
it's so mundane at the same time but
it's so insidious
yeah totally and it forces you to look
and think
in certain ways it forces you to conduct
yourself in certain ways and and
try to gauge how other people see you
and i i mean it can be really
anxiety provoking for shame shame
producing anxiety provoking
yeah even even the way we're discussing
power it's so
right now top down and even if it is top
down
the question that you should ask to
power is like what do i feel like i
should be
as soon as i walk out of my house and
obviously that's much different for
women's bodies than for men's bodies but
even
like how would you conduct yourself if
you knew someone might be watching
as opposed to how would you conduct
yourself if you knew someone
wasn't watching and this has a lot of
implications especially for sexuality
in terms of foucault particularly
because he wrote
the book literally on it but yeah how do
you conduct yourself
in what could be public space and then
even when you're in private space how do
you still internalize how you should be
acting in public space
in the way you respond only to yourself
and that's
that's power at its most fundamental
even just as fundamental as language too
language is infused with power relations
right like even
when we talk about legitimate power
we're using
a we're using a uh a legalistic metaphor
for power right do we ascend and a lot
of people for instance think that
wearing a mask
being forced to wear a mask is an
illegitimate
use of power on the on the part of the
state
but it's it's in our that's off the pot
topic yeah it's built into our language
as well the way we use language and the
way then as a result we sort of perceive
the world
and interact with each other it's very i
also just want to say eric
whenever you want to start the
revolution against louis vuitton or
dolce gabbana or something
i'll be right there in the street with
you right you know there's some things i
wouldn't march and fight for
but you know to end the rain uh you know
don't train cabana i'll be right there
yeah maybe maybe we're the only uh anti
anti-dolce gabbana
podcast yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] your gucci bag yeah i think
it's one of the interesting things too
because just drawing out what miriam was
saying earlier
i wonder if women have always occupied a
kind of peculiar position
when it comes to biopower and i know a
lot of feminist theorists have argued
this right
since women have historically
you know get putting aside all the
qualifications about sex and gender
right now
i've been the locus for the reproduction
of society
some have argued that the state has
always paid a peculiar amount of
attention
to their body and to their sexuality
since they're capable of doing something
that men fundamentally aren't
is that something that's worth exploring
well i would ask miriam because i've
never been a woman before so
aren't you um
i don't know that i can attest to the
veracity of that statement but
what do you mean exactly matt can you
can you say it again
well there are a number of feminist
theorists drawing on foucault
um we made the argument essentially that
well
one of the things that we need to talk
about when it comes to biological power
isn't necessarily these kinds of grand
things
that people talk about you know the
regulation of migration
or keeping um the polis pure
and some ethnic sense uh but actually
the kind of one more mundane activities
to police women's bodies and police
women's sexuality
precisely because the state has always
known that women are going to be
the primary caregivers the ones who are
responsible for reproducing
the native population and so it's always
taken a kind of special
interest in women's sexuality and
reproductive life
yeah yeah well just to make a precision
i think what when we are referring to
mundane like they
maintain expressions of power we're
referring to what focus is
micro power right like all these yeah
like
like biopower is a characteristic of
modern states
right for fukuoka it didn't exist
in states that are not modern of course
things that are not
kind of in this european tradition
i don't know if like free i would say
there are no
pre modern uses of biopower
in that sense maybe i have to think more
about that in
but i do agree that um what some people
call
patriarchy is biopower right like just
regulation of women's bodies it wasn't
one of the first
exercises how something like
biopower came around during the black
death
where like they were doing census data
on
and you know marking whose house
has had the had the bubonic plague and
i mean that's that's sort of in
foucault's mind where it all started
isn't it like that that sort of
laid the laid the model for them what
would be
come the sort of general modern state
was that
microcosm of the black plague
that's kind of neat though what does he
say about that
well about the about the black plague
right it has to do with uh
it's again this this discipline this
disciplinary force where you'd be
quarantined
in your house and you'd probably have a
big
red cross marked on your door right is i
think that's where the red cross
came from in the first places when the
plague victims had a red cross drawn on
their door
which was like a sort of very primitive
early modern exercise of biopower
it's like who's sick and who's healthy
and that's sort of where it all started
and then you just from there healthy
sick you get more subdivisions and more
subdivisions and
but that that that's where it all begins
and other other states don't have
that sort of idea of power their their
idea of power is more
like if you look at even lit like early
modern well
medieval literature like beowulf right
the way they are all positioned around
the table the way the women bring the
drinking horn from man to man
like that's a different exercise of
power it's more metaphorical it's more
analogical
or even if you look at like throwback
organizations like the masonic guilds or
something like that the way they
sit around the table is very reminiscent
of like the last suppers and
singing songs and that sort of stuff too
so
i don't know i'm i'm rambling now
somebody else take over miriam
marion i hope you can correct me on this
if it's uh
incorrect but um i think the best way to
understand biopower
is that the state always believes
and the state politicians in particular
they always believe then when they're
exerting biopower that they're doing it
in the interest
of the population it's never a mechanism
to actually hurt the population they say
no if we have all this data
and this might be interesting uh
relation to kovid in this case
so yeah you're totally right right for
fukuoka it's like
to go burn to administer to manage
the population right because yes as
you're saying
it is mostly referring a positive way
right how the state
wants as foucault said like make us
live right this was like a famous like
thing
but it can also have some
very necro political expressions
like genocide oh you're gonna have to
explain that so
the quote that you're saying right now
is um i think when he says sovereign
sovereign power controls death that
means they control when you die
if you like disobey your lord for
example then modern societies control
life that's they want you to be healthy
not just so that you can be like a good
worker but so that they can stay in
power more or less they want you to be
yeah so why don't you explain
necro politics as like a development
within that
modern state yeah like uh
didn't talk about this it was like the
later ideas developed like drawing up of
core right and micro politics basically
uh refers to this this state
even by omission and active participant
upon your death drive
i i don't know like yeah like saying go
go out and buy cove it doesn't matter we
don't need to worry about coverings
yes yes exactly or
if you think uh for example like
war seeking states
right like it states that's actively
wanna go to war for example
i i'll say that our other expressions of
necropolitics in the context of mexico
for example it's been
uh said that uh the necropolitical kind
of
dimensions or the state is when he the
state doesn't do anything to prevent
uh the killing of women right because
they are women
for example so i'll say that yeah most
of it is positive right how the state
wants you to live but it can have this
like
also uh when the state doesn't do
anything to prevent you from dying or
actively makes you die
i want to bring up like one final
example actually because this was a
really interesting one that i learned
about
some time ago and i can't [ __ ]
remember the name
of the author who did this study but she
drew on fukomi and accounts of
biopolitics and associated with a
feminist
um analysis and she pointed out the way
that prostitution
had been treated uh in england for about
200 years
and she pointed out interestingly enough
that like during the christian bach
prostitution was generally not seen as a
social problem because it was perceived
as
an individual expression of sinfulness
but because everyone was sinful it was
also broadly tolerated it's like well
there's nothing we can really do
to get rid of it people are falling and
they're going to give in to their bodily
urges
but starting in the 19th century with
the emergence of vitalistic philosophies
to go back to eric right in this kind of
scientific managerial style the state
took an intense institut
like interest in prostitution as
a instance of social vice where people
are going to be having children
outside of wedlock and that would
undermine the british empire's capacity
to actually control all of its territory
because
there wouldn't be enough children coming
from legitimate families to actually
replace those
who are inevitably going to die and
this was particularly like with
reference to the city of london where
during the 19th century
there were more prostitutes than ever
before
and at the same time there's this
extreme hyper regulation of people's
sexuality that you find expression
uh than all kinds of victorian novels
and the point that like
the author was trying to make is that
this goes to show you how it is that
women
have always occupied this very central
position
in the biopolitics of the state because
they're seeing on the one hand
as unnecessary and even the kind of
vital source for the reproduction of
society
and in this case the reproduction of
imperial british power
while at the same time they can
potentially be a great danger
if they engage in vice ridden activity
and have children out of wedlock which
will undermine
not just you know the individuals that
they're engaging with now but the whole
society as a whole uh like
in totem right and the british empire
will fall because there's too much of
this going on
and it's really interesting the kind of
drama that was associated with all this
this is exactly what the
the duality of power that we've been
talking about the whole time is like
yeah we need to protect
women but why do we need to protect them
it's because they're
raising the next generation of uh
of of men or something like that um
well not just men but like men who are
going to go into other countries to
impose
british will across the world right um
one thing i wanted to finish off because
we're we're sort of running up against
time here is uh the way that i
look at the way that power is discussed
at least online
which is sort of my new stomping ground
my new
my new area to do research in we have
not
a single time brought up capital except
for the very beginning of the discussion
but if you go into these online spaces
the only thing that they care about in
terms of power
is like jeff bezos
and mark zuckerberg and the democrats
and the republicans and they're all
colluding and this
this is what power is but i think what
we've done a good job of today
is we could have gone there at any point
if that was what we were concerned about
we probably will we probably will in the
future
but the point is that power is far more
mundane
than some people with money that dictate
people's decisions
power is inside of your brain
it's not inside of jeff bezos's brain
yeah that's a good point maybe yeah we
didn't go there maybe because
well one foucault is a little bit
hostile to
uh talking about maybe capital which
leads to marxist
right but foucault was not the topic
power was the topic but we just all
drifted to foucault
we kind of went we couldn't well
something something we didn't bring up
was
hegemony right right that's another form
we could do that in a future
discussed so when whenever you see some
people online
arguing about cultural elites and
cultural elitism
what they're talking about is gramscian
hegemony and it's almost
what what is the ruling class and
what ideology is being up imposed on us
from above
so jeff bezos and the silicon valley
whatever his [ __ ] name is in the and
the silicon valley technocrats right
there
they're the hedgehog at least for for
once it's not my pronunciation that's
being attacked so
academically did you see the
did you see the article i posted
yesterday eric the one by the federalist
yeah the one on the back of his people
yeah that's exactly it like
the federalists for those who don't know
is a far-right uh
basically blog where people talk about
how the united states is the greatest
country ever
and it's descendant of leftism is going
to destroy not just you know the united
states but the western world as a whole
but like the author of this piece who's
a phd student
was talking about the ideological
superstructure
and how it had been captured by the left
and how the goal of the political right
was to recapture control of the
ideological superstructure to establish
a new form of cultural hegemony and it
was amazing to me because i was like
i can't believe that in the 21st century
there are now conservatives who are
gramscians
there are conservative branches that
sounds crazy
so i don't want to go into neo-marxism
for this episode
because we're about at time um i just
thought it was interesting that
we we give the topic of power and we
just talk about foucault
the whole time which is not really
surprising because i think foucault is
the best
diagnostic of of power that we have
and the reason is just what miriam said
like at the beginning of this
conversation was that
it becomes your subjectivity and that's
what
true power is it's not something imposed
it's something that you
put into your own mind and then act it
out as if it's real
yeah i was gonna say it's one of the
perspectives like uh
like feminists prefer foucault but some
are also marx's feminists which we
didn't get into
would have been nice to talk about yeah
as i said this is gonna be probably a
six week
series and we've only done one thinker
uh miriam are you free next week if we
just want to do one
specific foucault book i was thinking
discipline and punish
sure yeah i love to discuss that book i
love that book and
unlike what uh victor i think was saying
i do think there's a lot of marks
in that book i actually have signaled it
to where it's called
being a marxist do you guys want to do
that next week well
sure it's going to be it's going to be
just
that's like that's a good that's a good
idea for a patreon only
yeah foucault our patrons
um so we're going to do final thoughts
and we're going to go
at least on my screen from right to left
so victor you're up first
what'd you get out what did you get out
of today and what do you think people
should get out of today
it was a winding conversation so it's a
tough question yeah it was a very
winding conversation that is a very
tough tough to thing to answer but i
guess like
uh i think like the important takeaway
like for for because i think foucault
like
the popular reading of foucault and like
these uh these accounts of power
like i'm like overemphasize the negative
aspect and i think like the important
like an important takeaway would just be
that like
power is is incorrectly interpreted if
it's just
talked about in a negative connotation
in some ways it's just like productive
of a social world
um and then there could be like good
versions of power and then bad version
and i think that's like an important
takeaway
all right matt
no i completely agree with brazoni on
that right i think
not speaking for everyone but kind of
speaking for everyone
the kind of consensus view i got was
that we all admit that or we all
think that power is pervasive and it
takes many different forms that can
exist in the mundane world as well in
these much more
spectacular forms if you talk about
state power but not all power is
intrinsically
negative if we evaluate it from a
normative point of view
and when it comes to trying to make
assessments about which kinds of power
we should accept and which ones we
should reject uh those are all very
complicated questions especially because
power is so all-pervasive
and it testifies to our need to have a
fairly robust moral outlook
in order to make these kind of subtle
judgments but that's a whole topic for
a different conversation right and then
uh marian how'd we do
i don't i don't think none of us have
read foucault as much as you or
as recently as you so was it all right
and what do you think our listeners
should get
out of foucault if nothing else
now if anything i was thinking eric is
uh
callie anna that's why i didn't want to
do this last week because eric
eric got eric got cancelled by the storm
yeah oh okay i did
no so oh yeah i i i think what you were
saying it's all right and
um i like football when talking about
power
because it allows us to think
in these many levels of about power you
can think of
how power is exercised from the state as
legal as biopolitics as biopower but you
can also think about all the other
institutions that also exercise power
in a disciplinary way right like the
school family
like religion like the church right and
it also allows you to think about
uh how power for example
uh shapes language as eric kind of
briefly mentioned
right like in spanish we have
um as you might know feminine and
masculine right and
when you wanna say in spanish you don't
say thank you
all you usually say thank you all the
men right for example that's a
way of excluding women and etc right so
but no i like to go because allows you
to think of all the different
ways in which what power is exercise and
all the different
uh effects that it has and like at the
level of the state or
subjectivity et cetera and that's why
i'm sorry i made this conversation about
football
you didn't excuse you didn't i think we
all did together
we would have just been shooting the
[ __ ] and been like remember that traffic
camera in saskatchewan
if you have any listeners in
saskatchewan we should point out that we
don't hate them
um we certainly don't think that we
don't have any maybe we will one day
well in the event that we do i just want
to point out that
just to reference our favorite canadian
thinker jp
jared and
yeah exactly when he says that women are
the angels of agents of chaos that's
wrong
we women bring the discipline
well that is definitely closer to my
experience of women
anyway eric you're left with the final
word
up on the pill pod on state power
yeah yeah sure i agree with all the
praise that was directed towards me
uh listen to what i say and take what
all these other clowns say for a grain
of salt
because my word is gospel that's a great
final thought no seriously
no i think uh i i wish we got into uh
more of my semiotic territory i would
have had a few more things to say about
uh speed bumps and traffic lights but uh
that's okay yeah we we got into one
dimension of power
and i think we dug in pretty deep but
there's a lot more out there to talk
about
and i i think those mundane
manifestations of power
are the most powerful yeah totally and
we have a few more weeks to do that
so we're gonna sign off we've been uh
through the ringer a little bit but i
think it was a productive discussion i
think it was fun i hope i hope
i hope everyone was tracking along i was
trying to intervene
on behalf of listeners that might have
not known what's going on but this is
you were being very you were being a
good disciplinarian
yeah exercising is show host power
no i gotta exactly i gotta discipline
you guys i gotta
really making that power dynamic quite
uneven between us
now the question is really that i gotta
internalize it into your mind so that
you can
stop dropping jargon and uh saying my
name on the podcast
specifically matt if i decide to say
your name that's an active resistance at
this point okay
all right hi i'm gonna say goodbye to
eric
adios bye miriam i hope you can come
back next week
bye bye uh matt
and yeah again matt you can't wave
because no one can see you
and victor i can wave all right
guys it's fun i'm looking forward to the
next one by the way i was also gonna say
we should maybe like uh record the video
on these one time and put them up on
youtube maybe
yeah oh my gosh i know you i know you're
freaking honey for the youtube
i'll get to it uh you'll be the first to
know okay okay bye
[Music]
[Music]
bye
you